okay so let's get straight into it if
you've been at Berkeley for at least a
week or even from your own institutions
you may have received an email recently
about increased incidences of lenss
around camp along campuses the Centers
for Disease Control has issued some
policies that people should follow is
there the right now if you can get your
flu shot you might be worrying that
maybe that was a good thing to do six
months ago but these guidelines I was
just curious are they informed by any
sort of study for college campuses and
it turns out that they are in 2011 there
was this paper published in the journal
virology about the 2009 pandemic h1n1
influenza at UCSD they wanted to
understand how this how the flu was
getting onto campus how was it mixing
was it you notice people were there
clusters in particular downes were there
classes on campus versus off-campus and
if you look in the methods section they
amongst all the others technical details
they mentioned that they used a relaxed
molecular clock and Bayesian skyline
coalescent prior and there's what
coalescent this model is what I'm going
to be talking about mostly for today off
of my lecture you could say it's a basic
model that underlines a lot underlies a
lot of genetic analysis sequence
analysis these days in these kinds of
applications they used mostly for
simulating genealogies but the call
lesson is actually an interesting
mathematical model in itself and so I'll
talk more about that so population
genetics these days involves thinking
forward and backwards in time there's
the right Fisher model which came first
and that was a forward in x model in
that you need a model for how
generations proceed follow other
generations but in the example I just
gave you before what the study was doing
was sampling the student population and
trying to understand well what processes
gave rise to those samples there's
observations so you need to think both
forwards and backwards in time and the
way we structured the free lectures is
that I'll talk about the basic models
and construct the coalescent which is
the basic backwards in time model on
speaking next we'll extend this model to
more realistic situations and that
finally Steve Evans will come and talk
about the forward forward in time
perspective which is also very
interesting even though in a lot of
papers these days you see mostly the
coalescent perspective applied
literature all right so let's begin with
the right Fischer model which was
developed in the 1930s the right Fischer
model is - well personally I think the
right Fischer model is - population
genetics what the simple symmetric
random walk is to stochastic processes
it's the basic thing you need to
understand to understand the rest of the
field so even though it may not have
that much relevance to a natural system
it is the natural starting point so what
we assume is that you have discrete non
overlapping generations that there's a
constant population size capital N and
the basic idea is that individuals pick
their parent uniformly at random from
the previous generation well this may
seem a bit strange
think about the even more basic
alternative which is you have a fixed
population size and everyone just gives
rise to one offspring every generation
that's even more boring this is adding a
bit more randomness which is the
previous sum the next generation is
composed of a multinomial sample from
the previous generation and Steve who's
going to talk more about forward in time
processes will give you a bit more of an
explanation for why this might make
sense right now I'm just going to say
that the probabilistic structure is that
each generation is formed by sampling
the previous generation and for now
we're not considering types we're now
considering mutation selection or
recombination so here's a picture of the
right Fisher model for words and time of
a population of size five so there you
have the first pop first generation and
the second generation the first
individual picked the first individual
from the previous generation as their
parent so did the second individual the
third individual picked the fourth the
fourth picked the fifth and the fifth
picked the fourth so as you can see not
everyone in each generation makes
offspring that has lost spring that can
be seen that make it to the next
generation and so this is the the
process forward in time now if we want
to understand you know given a sample
what may have given rise what processes
may have given rise to that sample we
want to understand what this process is
backwards in time so the way you do that
is you pick a sample so here we pick
samples one two three well four
individuals from the current generation
and we trace back with their ancestry so
their family tree and they actually all
trace back to only one individual from
the first generation and for the
remainder of this lecture I'm going to
focus on understanding this process so
we have a basic model for what how
generations are formed from the previous
generation going forward in time but
we're really trying to understand what
is the genealogy or the ancestral
process when we take that forward in
time process and run it backwards in
time okay so back so remember the key
point in the right Fischer model is that
individuals pick the parent uniformly at
random from the previous generation and
now we want to know
well when individuals going to have a
common ancestor that's that's how we
would get the ancestral process so the
first thing we want to know let's just
go line by line is the probability that
two individuals have distinct parents
and since each individual picks their
parent uniformly at random from the
previous generation well the first
individual can pick any of the in any of
the and individuals in the previous
generation so that's interv and that's
one and then the second individual just
has to not pick the same parent so
that's one minus one over n and once you
go back one generation you can repeat
the process for K generations because
there's the same thing once you go back
one generation they're still distinct
you iterate so the probability that two
individuals have distinct ancestors for
K generations is just 1 minus 1 over n
to the power of K so that's two
individuals having distinct ancestors
now let's generalize this to L
individuals having distinct ancestors
for K generations so if we just focus on
one generation
l individuals having distinct parents
you just generalize this for L
individuals so now the second guy can't
pick the first parent the third guy
can't pick any of the first two and so
on the elf guy can't pick any other
first L minus one yeah and then for K
generations you just take it to the
power of K and I think this is the
Kingman who then went on to develop the
standard coalescent did this sort of
calculation and saw that if you take
population size n to infinity and you
rescale time so that K generations well
so you rescale time so your unit of time
is n generations which means one unit K
generations corresponds to K over n that
probability converges to e to the
negative LL minus one over two times T
and that corresponds to the time to
coalescence when you have a sample of
Ellen individuals being exponentially
distributed with this rate and this is
the key insight that led to the
development of the the coalescence so
now let me give you the mathematical
construction of the well actually now
let me first illustrate what this
convergence means in figures so here is
your ancestral process for this five
individual population and then if you're
taking n to infinity you need to take
the population size to even fit Lajja
and you also have to take the number of
generations well number of time steps
Lajja so that's what happens and the
idea is if you're only sampling for
every time this ancestral process going
to converge to this coalescent which is
you have these lineages and they'll call
s at rate ll minus 1 over 2 when you
have L individuals in your sample all
right so now let's look at the
mathematical construction and this was
formalized by Kingman in 1982 I think
there were several of the people who
were thinking along these lines but the
the mathematical formulation happened
now in 1982 and if you remember the
right Fisher model was 1930s so there
were 50 years in between when you had
this forward in time model
when there was a formal description of
the backwards in time process so the end
coalescent is a coalescent that's our ik
continuous-time stochastic process it's
given by capital Pi and in square
brackets which is defined as just the
set of integers from 1 to N and it takes
values in the space of partitions open
and just to give you a feel for that
that means this is a you know graphical
interpretation of the N coalescent or
the full Collison
but if you want to write it in terms of
the space of partitions you have you
stop from occurring time with the
singleton partition and then one into
mudge so then you represent that by
putting 1 and 2 in the same set and then
3 and full merge and then finally the
last two lineages much and then you have
you've called us you've gone to the
single ancestor for the sample so
McCullough's and process is described by
the sequence of partitions and the
waiting times between the transitions
more formally you have an interval
condition which is the set of
Singleton's transition rates you
transition from one partition PI to
another partition PI prime at rate 1 if
PI prime is obtained by merging exactly
two blocks of Pi and otherwise you don't
the rate is zero and this is process
until you get to the absorbing state and
just a few remarks if you only look at
the number of blocks over time that's
given by this hash pie and that's a pure
death process with the death rate at
state L of that exponential rate and as
I said before the sequence of partitions
is independent of the number of how the
blocks change number of blocks change
over time so because of that it's
actually a quite an Isis quite a nice
process to study and let me just take a
minute to talk about some of the cute
mathematical properties of the
coalescent before I go more into the
applications of the car lesson so like I
said you have these two processes a
sequence of partitions and the waiting
times between the
merges so you can write down a
closed-form expression for the
probability distribution of the
Kingman's code lesson
another interesting fact probably
interesting only to mathematicians is
that the coalescing comes down from
affinity so I describe to you the end
coalescent which is you start with in
individuals and you look at the ancestry
back in time it actually makes
mathematical sense to define the color
sand siding from all the positive
integers so that's the infinity pot
that's called dust but if you run it for
any positive amount of time it becomes a
finite a finite partition with finite
numbers so it comes down from infinity
not all coalescence do that Kingman
coalescence does unrelated to this is
the Kingman coalesce other ancestral
processes that don't go this way so this
is a key moment this is a constructive
description of the Kingman's polis and
you don't have to make move this way
right and so there's I just refer to as
other colors so you could merge yeah and
I'll get to that later so related to
this concept of coming down from
infinity is this interesting fact that
if you project the N coalescent to a
smallest set of integers you get so say
m integers you get an M call lesson and
this actually is very obvious when you
think about it in terms of an ancestral
process if you have an ancestral process
for ten individuals and you're not
interested in the tenth individual
anymore you still have an ancestral
process for nine individuals but from
the perspective of a stochastic process
what you're doing is taking an N
dimensional something like an n
dimensions and you're projecting into a
lower dimensional space and it still
preserves the same properties and that
is quite surprising okay so these Q
properties aside why is it that we study
the Collison
I've given you the derivation of the car
lesson from the right Fisher model which
is although a basic model is just one
model of how populations can change over
time as it turns out the car lesson is
the limiting process for a large family
of reproduction models
and to characterize this large family I
need to define the Cannings model sir
the Cannings model is defined by these
vectors u sub 1 through N and is still
our population size and the mathematical
characterization is just that these new
sub I are exchangeable integer valued
random variables and they have to sum to
n
exchangeable in an intuitive sense just
means you can real able these news and
you still get the same probability
distributions for all your calculations
so they're sort of it doesn't matter how
you label your individuals your results
are always going to be the same the
biological interpretation as that new
sub I is the number of offspring left by
individual I from the previous
generation so in the right Fisher model
these new sub I multinomial with
probability 1 of n but you can see that
there are many other possibilities for
how you define the specter of offspring
so ml of proved in 2000 that let me just
preface this with so not all Candy's
models will give you a Kingman's call
lesson and mela proved that if this
limit is true in a Cannings model then
the genealogy of the sample of
population converges to the Kingman's
coalescent so what does this fraction
mean well the the numerator is the rate
is approximately you can think of
morally the probability that three
blocks merge into one block and the
denominator is the probability that two
blocks merge into one block so all this
is saying is that the rate at which
three merges occur vanishes relative to
the rate at which two merges occur and
that makes sense because Kimmons
coalesce and only really I didn't
specify this but it only allows binary
merges and you can imagine if you have a
population model given by Kang's model
where 3 merges are possible and you know
on the same order of magnitude as 2
merges then you wouldn't get ki
call us and because you'd expect three
mergers and kingpins coalescent doesn't
have them so that's why
Kingman's call us and is studied quite a
lot because it has this universality yes
sorry I changed notation halfway through
my presentation all right go back to it
begin so so far I've told you about
these ancestral process of the right
Fisher model and I've told you that the
car lesson is the limit of that
ancestral process and that is also the
limit of a lot of sort of that right
Fisher model and it's also the limiting
process for a lot of other models but I
haven't talked about types of mutation
or anything like that I've only talked
about what is the family tree or the
sample so now let's suppose that we were
interested in the types of the
individuals not just their genealogy and
the nice thing about the coalescent if
you have no selection is that mutation
can just be a process a plus on process
on top of this tree so there's the tree
which is that alcohol lesson and then we
drop mutations at a Poisson rate of
theta over two onto this tree I'll
explain why we divide theta of the two
on the next slide now the interpretation
of what the result of this process is
depends on what assumptions you're
making about mutations so two common
mutation models are the infinite alleles
model and the infinite sites model and
the Infinity alleles model assumes that
each mutation leads to a distinct allele
so every time there's a mutation you
have a new type so if you are numbering
your types by by the integers every time
there's a new mutation you increase the
integer that you're labeling your types
with and the motivation for this kind of
assumption I think was because before
sequencing the data that biologists
collected were over the form of these
allelic partitions where a sub 1 equals
18 means there were 18 types that only
had one individual representing them a
sub 2 equals 3 meant that there were 3
types that had 2 and
vigils representing that type and here a
sub 32 equals 1 means there was one type
of one allele where there were 32
representatives and the individual in
the population in the sample and they
wanted to understand well is is this
typical what can we say about this
allelic partition and this was touched
on in Monty's talk which was you can
calculate the you know the distribution
on these allelic partitions using U and
sampling formula UN sampling formula
came before Kingman's coalescent but you
can use Kingman's coalescent to derive I
think like given another derivation of U
and sampling formula and I put this up
mainly because you can see here theta
appears nicely this way so that's why
typically you say the mutation process
is plus on rate theta over 2 so that's
infinite alleles and now that we have
more sequence data infinite sites seems
to be more relevant so here you assume
that each mutation occurs on a distinct
side so before each mutation led to a
new type now we assume we actually do
have a sequence and that every time a
mutation occurs because there are so
many sites the probability that you hit
the same side is so low that every
mutation just occurs on a new site and
again you drop mutations on like a
Poisson process but now we're going to
just label them because the way we're
going to account do the accounting
requires this labeling and whereas
before you had the allelic partition
here it's not so clear like if you have
a new site and you have a mutation on
your site what the what object to look
at so to illustrate this what I've done
is I've on this table you have all the
different mutations and these are the
individuals so individuals one and two
just experience one mutation at site 3
so I wanted to have a one here that
means they have a mutant at that site 3
and 4 well 3 had 2 mutations on 1 and 2
and then 4 had 3 mutations so you have
this kind of data that's generated from
the coalescent with mutation assuming an
infinite size
model and here the the thing that we are
interested in looking at is called a
side frequency spectrum which is for a
sample of size and I think I was
supposed to have a little case in sample
size for sample of size and sigh and I
is the number of sites at which exactly
I individuals carry a mutation so for
example here site three has two
individuals carrying one mutation side
four has one individual carrying one
mutation so this is the kind of
statistic you look at when you assume an
infinite sized model the mutation is you
usually it's infinite size and infinite
alleles and the kind of work is done
based on size frequency spectrum or the
only like partition and there's more
theory that can be done to calculate
statistics about those two objects so
moving on from the basic humans call us
an A mutation I want to talk about when
humans coalescent is not appropriate and
what kind of other coalescence might be
relevant so the humans call lesson is
not appropriate for a few for many
reasons here are three one is if there's
a population bottleneck so if you have a
new populations that's seeded by a very
small population then if you went
backwards in time you would expect a lot
of individuals to have the same ancestor
very quickly similar similarly you can
have a selective sweep from beneficial
mutations so if there's a mutation say
in bacteria that confers antibiotic
resistance and then you apply
antibiotics to this colony of bacteria
then only a few bacteria survive a you
know the rest of the popula they fill up
the rest of the population and so if you
look at this process back in time again
you'd expect a lot of coalescing events
and finally large variability and
offspring distribution can also give
rise to situations where the humans
coalescing is not appropriate the main
example and this is marine populations
and specifically oysters so apparently
oysters a
Widespread spatially but the genetic
variation from generation to generation
is quite low which leads people to
believe that each new generation of
oysters is founded by just a very small
number of oysters from the previous
generation and again if that's the case
if you're running the process backwards
in time you'd expect a lot of
individuals to have the same ancestor
very sooner than you would expect on the
Kingman's call lesson it might be I know
that there's some work on HIV in that
direction but I don't think it's an area
I not familiar with that area of
research I haven't come across it so
this this leads us to look for other
coalescence and now I will define what I
need by other coalescence so the lambda
coalescent is actually just a subset of
the other color since you can have but
it allows for two blocks to call s into
one block you can have multiple
coalescence to multiple blocks but the
lambda call us in only an aisle
allows multiple coalescence to one block
and the lambda colistin is specified by
this lowercase lambda B K which is the
rate at which a particular K topple of
looks out of the block smudges and the
reason why it's a capital lambda
coalescent is because pitman in 1999
ensured that the coalescent process the
coalescent process is associated with
this lambda can be uniquely
characterized by this finite measure
capital lambda and it's because of this
characterization that these processes
are called the Lamb to call lesson so
let me just give go back to my analogy
with stochastic processes I said write
Fisher model is like the simple
symmetric random walk for stochastic
processes and population genetics
Kingman's coalescing is like Brownian
motion a lot of things converge to it
but not everything converges to it and
the lambda coalescent is like levy
processes if people people familiar with
that area
they might understand um I think it's
useful to have that analogy there was a
question oh yeah right better if I just
show you the picture or these are blocks
these are subsets
they're also called linkages so the
lambda sub KB is just the rate at which
these blocks convince merge into single
blocks all right sir the probability
that there's an event that causes k k
box to converge to be you're thinking of
it as a binomial the P in the binomial
distribution it's related to that so if
you take this X to the negative 2 and
put it under this lambda then this is a
binomial probability and then this
measure has another interpretation so
it's not so X in that context yes but
then how do you interpret it in the
broader context it's not as it is not so
straightforward all right sir I've
talked about the basic building block
right Fisher model Steve Evans will go
back and talk more about that
the Keynes call I sent the standard
vanilla call essent how you put mutation
on to the coalescence and then in these
certain circumstances when you can have
multiple blocks merging what might be a
reasonable approximation to that the
lambda coalescent I haven't mentioned
recombination I haven't mentioned
selection I haven't mentioned population
size is changing so in the next two
lectures I hope you'll come back after
lunch on and we'll talk about how the
coalescent can handle the recombination
what happens when the population size
isn't constant which is often the case
and I've only talked about the backwards
in time perspective but there are many
advantages for using a Poisson time
perspective and particularly you can
handle selection more easily I think
so and that's what's coming next and for
those who are interested in references
these are just a few that I found
helpful to get some background on this
topic ok that's it
which is what people use this for for
simulating genealogies sir I just talked
in that first paper I showed you they
wanted to understand how we took samples
from all these students well what may
have given rise to them a lot of times
they'll build a phylogenetic tree from
the samples but to understand whether
this tree is typical or atypical year to
find out what distribution that tree
comes from you need to have a concept of
what is a random tree and I think a col
lesson in those situations is commonly
used as a way to simulate a random
genealogy does that answer your question
you got data and you build first build a
tree so yeah originally it was done that
way now they're a software like beast
and what they'll do is they'll take a
coalescing of the prior and then given
the static they'll calculate a posterior
so it underlies a lot of the analysis
that's done and if other people will
have other uses for the colonists in an
application
feel free to chime in but it it's at the
basic at the very basic level a
coalescence of being used to generate
trees you wouldn't actually I don't
think you'd manually do that now I think
you would use the software
from the color yeah for so say you're
collecting data and you can match it to
the size frequency spectrum assuming the
coalescent you can calculate statistics
on the sec sequence your spectrum so i
would have some site frequency spectrum
from data and then I would look to see
if that showed up in my coalescent model
by varying parameters I think that's one
way can you say just a word or two about
how beast works I wish I could but I'm
not as familiar with the software I know
it exists and I know that they have Cola
surprise but that's the extent of my
knowledge you have two parents so if you
have a diploid population okay um I
think the most basic thing to do when
you have two parents is you assume that
each individual has two copies of their
genes so instead of n you have two in
and you still think of the process going
back in time as you know one of your I'm
going to use their own terminology 1/2
so you just each individual is now two
individuals under that half point if you
want to include recombination which is
what which is a more complex issue then
Anand will tell you in the next lecture
the nice thing is that even if
individuals have two parents each allele
that that individual has just come from
one parent
it's not like that your parents get like
perfectly mixed together anything
I think there is something canoe
explain again why the lung decor lesson
is better suited for no
oh right so to be careful in my
terminology it's not so much that it's
better suited for non neutral models
because if the selection is not very
strong it's still not I don't think it's
still a very good model but when you
have such strong selection that a large
fraction of your next generation comes
from one individual then that
corresponds to having multiple blocks
coalescing backwards in time so in that
situation it might be that a lambda kala
some models the purse as well but the
lambda coalescent in its assumption
because you still have them I forgot to
mention you still need exchangeable
ability exchangeability sort of implies
that each individual is sort of the same
relative to the other individuals it
isn't consistent with having selection
acting on the population sign to most
recent common ancestor for instance
he's still stuck to the bottom a cordis
like right